désormais toutes les chances d'être
officiellement inculpé cela très
rapidement
il ya en france 70 milles divorces par
an avec à peu près 60% de consentement
mutuel et 40% de conflit il ya également
plus de 70000 enfant confié à
l'assistance publique à la suite de ces
différences le divorce est donc
aujourd'hui un phénomène courant dans
notre société et ce sont bien évidemment
les enfants qui en général train dont
les parents se déchirent les enfants du
divorce est depuis hier le thème d'une
semaine dans quelle proposé par monique
kara dans notre magazine c'est la vie à
18h30 chaque soir lorsqu'un homme et une
femme divorce leurs enfants les juges et
leur jugement
vous allez le voir et sans complaisance
car elle avait tu je fais n'y ait au
moins tu comprendras toi-même aussi à se
plaindre de moi à se plaindre de moi
écrit un petit peu plus vite mais
applique toi rhin j'ai terminé là bien
alors tu relis la récitation tueur et
l'état dictée et je vais voir bertrand
janvier les enfants ce ne sont pas des
célèbres comme les autres dans la mesure
où j'ai pu prendre en ce moment quelques
précautions et sur le plan de leur
sécurité parce que j'ai la sensibilité
de leur éducation et je veux l'assumer
mais au niveau des résultats au niveau
des méthodes l'éducation se fait sous le
contrôle d'une école avec des séjours à
irrégulière à l'école je participe
d'ailleurs moi même j'ai au moins deux
demi journées avec les professeurs à
l'école et avec les enfants en même
temps dis-moi clair il ya eu des
problèmes il ya quelques temps
oui peut me raconter belle maman nous a
regardé trop longtemps et puis tu as pas
l it et rui si tu es ce que voulait le
voir en vie
on prie on s'est approché la voiture
comme maman mon mari dit si tu avais dit
quoi ta maman ma musique
surtout il fallait très bien se débattre
info il fallait pas il fallait pas c'est
faire faire par papa et puis alors
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous de ces
disputes entre ton papa et à maman pour
vous avoir tous et à très s'est pas
vraiment facile et ccib est déviée vers
ces nouvelles entre papa et maman je me
dis allez dehors je peux pas me laisser
y eut aussi parce que non
on se balade un côté après de l'autre
c'est dur quand même tu vas tu conduis
faire comme ça j'en ai trouvé une
méthode de re pourquoi ça je le
souhaiterais c'est une chose qui
pourrait à mon avis parfaitement se
faire dans la mesure où méthodes
d'éducation serait semblable
or ma femme est partie au milieu d'une
crise mystique au écologique et lorsque
un enfant a mal aux dents je l'envoie
chez le dentiste avec lui chez le
dentiste
quand ma femme a de son côté avec ses
amis et de la soigner des maux de dents
elle met un clou de girofle avec de
l'argile
enfin je le sais parce que mes enfants
me l'ont dit j'imagine que c'est vrai
alors on ne peut pas c'est soit sa
méthode soit la mieux parler d'eux d'où
le drame de ceux de mon divorce à moi ce
n'est pas un divorce ou les méthodes
d'éducation sont semblables tout tout
est opposé et tout ce que je fais moi
tout ce que je dis moi quand les enfants
sont là-bas et la maman essaie de
détruire tout ce qui est il et tout ça
mais je pense que nous concevons d'un
côté 11 passes de l'autre on est comme
des
il sert à rien de rien à voir c'est
avant tout parce qu'une je pense ça
marche qu'on s'installe en jeu pourtant
sa part oui des valises qui vous donne
parfois envie un peu de pleurer